well i wish i had something better to
start with today
i do but unfortunately coveted cases in
the united states
are absolutely exploding thanks to not
having vaccinated
nearly enough americans yet and because
of the unvaccinated doing things that
they really should not be doing
plus the highly contagious delta variant
and
understandably the vaccinated are
growing
increasingly furious with the
unvaccinated
who refuse to take the steps that
everybody can take
to help end this pandemic i mean aren't
we sick of this
wouldn't you accept and willingly and
excitedly
go towards an action if there was
something you
could do to help end this pandemic they
won't get vaccinated
they won't wear masks and they'll insist
on large gatherings of unvaccinated
people
cnn reporting that some vaccinated
americans have lost their patience
with those refusing the shot as covid19
cases surge
and mandates return we'll tell you in a
bit about what's been going on in
florida
the washington post reporting that quote
vaccinated people
are ready for normalcy and angry
at the unvaccinated getting in their way
they claim to want everything to go back
the normal
back to normal and in fact many of them
never thought we needed to depart from
normal even in may june uh whenever of
2020 in the middle of the pandemic they
never wanted to do anything
and yet they won't do the things
that would help us get back to normal
and you know what
it's correct to be resentful of these
people
you know at the start of the pandemic
things
were crazy we didn't know how contagious
or deadly covid was we didn't know how
much social distancing would work or
to what degree masks would mitigate the
spread and
there were differences of opinion in the
midst of
not yet having full information and
while it started to become
clear that there were some bad faith
actors there were
there were still more unknowns about
what needed to be done and then
when it became clear well okay yeah the
masks we need
we need to stop large indoor gatherings
the bleaching your papayas
that didn't make sense but these other
things did
and we learned more and more and they
still didn't do anything
then it was frustrating i think is the
way i would describe it
and then the vaccines became completely
widely available
i mean in a way that other countries can
only dream of and
a ton of those other countries are
desperate for vaccines and yet here
you have tens of millions of people who
just won't get vaccinated instead
they are uh more interested in spreading
vaccine
disinformation and conspiracy theories
wildly
irresponsibly and humiliatingly that's
their choice and so
now we have another surge it's mostly
unvaccinated people getting sick and
and mostly unvaccinated people getting
seriously sick
and overwhelmingly unvaccinated people
dying but
not only covet is here uh
it's endemic and we are now stuck with
these people
in a veritable idiocracy so now it is
anger and now it is reset resentment and
now it's fury and its desperation and
the world looks at us and wonders what
on earth is going on over there
we're desperate for vaccines we want oh
wow we just
i think uh joe biden just sent like four
million
vaccines to nigeria maybe it was you
know small small numbers
we have hundreds of millions you just
walk in and you get vaccinated and
you're almost certain not to get
seriously sick from covid
and they won't do it so i i have to tell
you before this pandemic
i knew how partisan and divided the
country was
over political issues but i guess
naively
i thought if something serious happened
like a pandemic we would come together
and do what needs to be done
across party lines what an idiot i was i
mean boy was i wrong
my faith in even the most basic ability
to count on the united states as a
society
to do simple things wear masks when it
makes sense to wear masks
get yourself vaccinated when you can
which is now for
everybody who's 12 or older play by the
rules don't spread insane conspiracy
theories about a virus
my faith has been completely eroded by
what we've seen i was reminded
of a kurt vonnegut quote that applies
perfectly to our situation here in the
united states
true terror is to wake up one morning
and discover
that your high school class is running
the country now my high school class was
actually okay there were lots of smart
people
but a lot of my high school classmates
are also spreading conspiracies on
facebook
so it's more like we've woken up and the
people who had no business
running a lemonade stand in high school
are now running the country and part of
it has to be
past generations didn't have such ready
access to misinformation
and conspiracies about anything that
happened like they had it with a lot of
stuff there was war propaganda
whatever but now there is no break to
the signal boost
if you get a notion in your head that
the vaccines are evil
and bill gates and whatever you can just
go on facebook
or wherever and you can find information
that just reinforces that hair brain
belief where
in times past on some issues there's
always been propaganda but
on some issues there was not such an
easy way to signal boost
any crazy notion that you had you don't
really want to accept the science well
here's a full social media platform from
uncle bob
when and you can choose to just insulate
yourself
with that stuff so we are in real real
trouble here
and um as as i've been telling you guys
uh
we are starting to see this delta wave
pass in europe i mentioned i'm going to
be in spain next week and we'll
have some great guest hosts here uh it
looks like spain
uk and other places they are they are
seeing a rapid decline
after the delta variant uh took hold
there as
vaccination continues and many of these
countries including spain have surpassed
the u.s
in percentage of people vaccinated we'll
look at those numbers a little later
it's not clear how long the numbers are
going to continue worsening in the
united states we're at a hundred
thousand cases a day again
and we'll look at that a little bit
later um
florida it's unconscionable what's
happening
record hospitalizations in florida like
record going all the way back to the
beginning
so we're in real trouble and it's
correct it makes sense
that the resentment of the people who
just choose not to get vaccinated
is growing dramatically one of our
sponsors today is
bluechu a unique online service
delivering
the same active ingredients as viagra
and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction
of the cost and they're giving my
audience an entire
month supply for free so if you think
you could benefit from an extra boost
of confidence when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days
in a discreet package no driving around
to the doctor's office or the pharmacy
no waiting around
no awkward conversations with your
doctor all of blue chews tablets are
made
in the usa the entire process is just a
few clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire
month's supply for free when you use the
promo code
pacman all you have to do is pay five
dollars shipping